ان شاء الله ان شاء الله لا اله الا
الله بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين وما من
دابه في الارض الا عيام وكان عرشه على
الماء ليبلوكم ايكم احسن
عملا ولئن قلت انكم مبعوثون من بعد الم
المت
ليقين ولئن اخرنا عنهم العذاب الى
امه معدوده
ليقولن ما
يحبسه الا يوم ياتيهم ليس مصروفا عنهم
وحاق بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون ولئن اذقنا الانسان منا رحمه ثم
نزعنا ها منه انه ليوس
كفور ولئن اذقناه
نعماء بعد
ضراء مسته ليقولن ذهب السيئات عن صبروا
وعملوا الصالحات
اولئك لهم مغف تارك بعض ما يوحى اليك وضا
الله على كلتم ص نوفي اليهم لهم في الاخره
الا
النار وحبط ما صنعوا
فيها سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله اكبر اياك نعبد
واياك شاهد ائك يؤمنون به ومن بفنون الله
من
اولياء يضاعف لهم
العذاب ما كانوا يستطيعون السمع وما كانوا
يبصرون
اولئك الذين خسروا انفسهم وضل عنهم ما
كانوا
يفترون لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم الاخس
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات واخبتوا
الى ربهم ا اصحاب الجنه هم فيها
خالدون مثل الفريقين كالاعمى والاصم
والبصير والسميع هل يستويان مثلا افلا
تذكرون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله الله
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
لام
‏se
[Silence]
ا
صلاه القيام اثابكم الله استقيم
واستو استقيموا
واستووا
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه اني لكم
نذير مبين الا تعبدوا الا الله اني اخاف
عليكم عذاب يوم
اليم فقال الملا الذي الذين كفروا من قومه
ما نراك الا بشرا مثلنا وما نراك اتبعك
الا الذين هم اراذلنا بادي
الراي وما نرى لكم علينا من فضل بل نظنكم
كاذبين قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على
بينه من ربي واتاني رحمه
من عنده فعميت
عليكم فعميت عليكم انلزمكموها
وانتم لها
كارهون ويا قوم لا اسالكم عليه مالا ان
اجري الا على الله وما انا بطارد الذين
امنوا انهم ملاقوا ربهم ولكني اراكم قوما
تجهلون ويا قوم من ينصرني من الله ان
طردتهم افلا
تذكرون ولا اقول لكم عندي
خزائن الله ولا اعلم الغيب ولا اقول اني
ملك ولا اقول للذين تزدري اعينكم لن
يؤتيهم الله خيرا الله ا بما في
انفسهم اني اذا لمن
الظالمين قالوا يا نوح قد جادلتنا فاكثرت
جدالنا فاتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال انما ياتيكم به الله ان
شاء وما انتم بمعجزين
ولا ينفعكم نصحي ان اردت ان انصح لكم ان
كان الله يريد ان
يغويكم هو ربكم واليه
ترجعون ام يقولون
افتراه قل ان افتريته فعلي اجرامي وانا
بريء مما
تجرمون واوحي الى نوح ان انه لن يؤمن من
قومك الا من قد امن فلا تبتئس بما كانوا
يفعلون واصنع الفلك باعيننا ووحينا ولا
تخاطبني في الذين ظلموا
انهم
مغرقون ويصنع الفلك وكلما مر عليه ملا من
قومه سخروا منه قال ان تسخروا منا
فانا نسخر منكم كما
تسخرون فسوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخزيه
ويحل عليه عذاب
مقيم حتى اذا
جاء امرنا وفارت النور قل نحمل فيها قل
نحمل فيها من كل زوجين اثنين واهلك الا من
سبق عليه القول ومن
امن وما امن معه الا
قليل وقال اركبوا فيها بسم الله مجريها
ومرساها ان ربي لغفور
رحيم وهي تجري بهم في موج ك الجبال ونادى
نوح ابنه وكان في معزل يا بني
اركم معنا يا بني اركم معنا ولا تكن مع
الكافرين قال ساوي الى جبل يعصمني من
الماء قال لا عاصم اليوم من امر الله الا
من رحم وحال بينهما الموج فكان من
المغرقين وقيل يا ارض ابلعي ماءك ويا
سماء اقلعي وغيض
الماء وقضي الامر واستوت على
الجودي وقيل بعدا للقوم
الظالمين ونادى نوح ربه فقال رب ان بني من
اهلي وان وعدك الحق وانت احكم
الحاكمين قال يا نوح انه ليس من اهلك انه
عمل غير
صالح فلا تسالني ما ليس لك به علم اني
اعظك ان تكون من
الجاهلين قال رب اني اعوذ بك ان اسالك ما
ليس لي به علم والا تغفر لي وترحمني اكن
من
الخاسرين قيل يا نوح اهبط بسلام منا
وبركات عليك وعلى امم ممن معك وامم
سنمتعهم ثم يمسهم منا عذاب
اليم تلك من ان
انباء الغيب نوحيها اليك ما كنت تعلمها
انت ولا قومك من قبل
هذا فاصبر ان العاقبه
للمتقين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط الم
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى عاد اخاهم هودا قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره ان انتم
الا
مفترون يا قوم لا اسالكم عليه اجرا ان
اجري الا على الذي فطرني افلا
تعقلون ويا قوم استغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا
اليه يرسل
السماء عليكم
مدرارا يرسل
السماء عليكم مدرارا ويزدكم قوه الى قوتكم
ولا تتولوا
مجرمين قالوا يا هود ما جئتنا
ببينه وما نحن بتاركي الهتنا عن قولك وما
نحن لك
بمؤمنين ان نقول الا اعتراك بعض الهتنا
بسوء قال اني اشهد الله واشهد
اني
بريء مما
تشركون من دونه فكيدوني جميعا ثم لا
تنظرون اني توكلت على الله ربي وربكم ما
من
دابه الا هو اخذ
بناصيتها ان ربي على صراط
مستقيم فان تولوا فقد ابلغتكم ما ارسلت به
اليكم ويستخلف ربي قوما غيركم ولا
تضروني
ان ربي على كل شيء
حفيظ ولما
جاء امرنا نجينا هودا وال الذين امنوا معه
برحمه منا
ونجيناهم من عذاب
غليظ وتلك
عاد جحدوا بايات ربهم وعصوا رسله واتبعوا
امر كل جبار
عنيد واتبعوا في هذه الدنيا لعنه ويوم
القيامه الا ان عادا كفروا ربهم الا بعد
الاعاد قوم
هود الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏ja
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين والى ثمود اخاهم صالحا قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره هو انشاكم
من الارض واستعمركم فيها فاستغفروه ثم
توبوا
اليه فاستغفروه ثم توبوا اليه ان ربي قريب
مجيب قالوا يا صالح قد كنت فينا مرجوا قبل
هذا اتهانا ان نعبد ما يعبد اباؤنا واننا
لفي شك مما تدعونا اليه
مريب قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه
من ربي واتاني منه رحمه فمن ينصرني من
الله ان عصيته فما تزيدونني غير
تخسير ويا قوم هذه ناقه الله لكم ايه لكم
ايه فذروها تاكل في ارض
الله ولا تمسوها
بسوء فياخذ عذاب
قريب فعقروها فقال تمتعوا في داركم ثلاثه
ايام ذلك وعد غير
مكذوب فلما
جاء امرنا نجينا صالحا والذين امنوا معه
برحمه منا ومن خزي
يومئذ ان ربك هو القوي
العزيز واخذ الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا
في ديارهم
جاثمين كان لم يغنوا فيها الا ان ثمود
كفروا ربهم الا بدا
لثمود ولقد جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى
قالوا سلاما قال سلام فما لبث ان جا
بعجل
حنيذ فلما راى ايديهم لا تصل اليه نكرهم
واوجسبورج
[Silence]
اسحاق
يعقوب قالت يا ويلتا االد وانا عجوز وهذا
بعلي شيخا ان هذا لشيء
عجيب قالوا اتعجبين من امر الله رحمه الله
وبركاته عليكم اهل
البيت
انه حميد
مجيد
فلما ذهب عن ابراهيم الروع
وجاءته البشرى يجادلنا في قوم لوط ان
ابراهيم لحليم اواهم
منيب يا ابراهيم اعرض عن هذا انه قد جاء
امر ربك وانهم اتيهم عذاب غير مردود
ولما جاءت رسلنا لوطا
سيء بهم وضاق بهم ذرعا وقال هذا يوم عصيب
وجاءه قومه يهرعون اليه ومن قبل كانوا
يعملون
السيئات قال يا قوم
هؤلاء بناتي هن اطهر لكم فاتقوا الله
ولا تخزوني في
ضيفي اليس منكم رجل
رشيد قالوا لقد علمت ما لنا في بناتك من
حق وانك لتعلم ما
نريد قال لو ان لي بكم قوه او اوي الى ركن
شديد قالوا يا لوط انا رسل ربك لن يصلوا
اليك فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل ولا يلتفت
منكم احد الا امراتك انهه مصيبها ما
اصابهم ان موعدهم الصبح اليس الصبح
بقريب فلما جاء امرنا جعلنا فلما جاء
امرنا جعلنا عاليها س ف لها وامطرنا عليها
حجاره من
سجيل
حجاره من سجيل
منضود مسومه عند ربك وما هي من الظالمين
ببعيد الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره ولا تنقص
المكيال
والميزان ولا تنقص المكيال والميزان اني
اراكم بخير واني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم
محيط ويا قوم اوفوا المكيال والميزان
بالقسط ولا تبخسوا الناس
اشياءهم ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين بقيه الله خير لكم ان كنتم مؤمنين
وما انا عليكم
بحفيظ قالوا يا شعيب اصلاتك تامرك ان نترك
ما يعبد
اباؤنا او ان نفعل في اموالنا ما
نشاء انك لانت الحليم
الرشيد قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه
من ربي ورزقني منه رزقا حسنا وما اريد ان
اخالفكم الى ما انهاكم عنه ان اريد الا
الاصلاح ما
استطعت وما توفيقي الا بالله عليه توكلت
واليه
انيب ويا قوم لا يجرمنكم شقاقي ان يصيبكم
مثل ما اصاب قوم نوح او قوم هود او قوم
صالح وما قوم لوط من وما قوم لوط منكم
ببعيد واستغفر ربكم ثم توبوا اليه ان ربي
رحيم
ودود قالوا يا شعيب ما نفقه
كثيرا مما تقول وان لنراك فينا
ضعيفا ولولا رهتك لرجمناك وما انت علينا
بعزيز قال يا قوم ارهطي اعز عليكم من الله
واتخذتموه
وراءكم
ظهريا ان ربي بما تعملون
محيط ويا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم اني عامل
سوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخذ من ياتيه
عذاب يخزيه ومن هو كاذب وارتقي
اني معكم
رقيب ولما جاء امرنا نجينا شعيبا والذين
امنوا معه برحمه
منا واخذت الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا في
ديارهم
جاثمين كان لم يغنوا فيها الا بعدا لمدين
كما بعدت ثمود
ولقد ارسلنا موسى
باياتنا
وسلطان
مبين الى فرعون وملاه فاتبعوا امر
فرعون وما امر فرعون
برشيد يقدم قومه يوم القيامه فاوردهم
النار وبئس الورد
المورود واتبعوا في هذه لعنه ويوم القيامه
بئس الرفد
المرفود ذلك من
انباء القران ن قصه عليك منها
قائم
وحصيد وما ظلمناهم ولكن ظلموا انفسهم فما
اغنت عنهم الهتهم التي يدعون من دون لله
من شيء لما
جاء امر
ربك وما زادوهم غير
تتبيب وكذلك اخذ ربك اذا اخذ القرى وهي
ظالمه ان اخذه
اليم
شديد ان في ذلك ان في ذلك لايه لمن خاف
عذاب
الاخره ذلك يوم مجموع له الناس وذلك
يوم
مشهود وما نؤخره الا
لاجل
معدود يوم ياتي لا تكلم نفس الا باذنه
فمنهم شقي
وسعيد فاما الذين شقوا ففي النار لهم فيها
زفير
وشهيق خالدين فيها ما دامت السماوات
والارض الا ما
شاء ربك ان ربك فعال لما
يريد واما الذين سعدوا ففي الجنه خالدين
فيها ما دامت السماوات والارض الا ما
شاء
ربك
عطاء غير
مجذوذ الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏to
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومنه ومن تبعه باحسان يوم
الدين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك و ودك محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين ان شا
الله
عليه خ
[Silence]
يه
ض
خ was
woman not woman
tion was either
‏happ
be was
in
and محم ى الله
عليهم person
in and
every
wass
[Silence]
عليه
‏one
عليه be mar her there some
different there ‏mention happ the
popular
the is howen there are some other
narration somei who
mention father
father
mention vi vera regard popular opinion
ised عل and take as the
الله خ
[Silence]
لام
‏husb passed so now not only is a
also
so
sayes
[Silence]
15 عليه
‏like
aer
woman say always
are
equ
[Silence]
‏around
2 عليه
الهلام
خضن
كثير عليهل
‏there
year
of bes that particular what
happ
[Silence]
لام عليه
‏care
[Silence]
صل عليه
وس
was عليهه
واللام
‏ins
character
لام
حق لا اله الا الله محد رسول
اللهه محد الله ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه
وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا اذاب النار ونا عذاب
القبر ونا عبنم ونا عتنه الممات ع مسح
الجال ربنا تقبلنا انك السميع اليم وتب
علينا يا مواب الرحيم صلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحتك الرحمين
اللهم امين اللين
اللين شا الله
حاالك
الله
‏sto
سفو
[Silence]
شيطان
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين فلا تق في مريه مما يعبدها
ؤلاء ما يعبدون الا كما يعبد
اباؤهم من قبل
وانا لموفوهم نصيبهم غير
منقوص ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف
فيه ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم
وان هم لفي شك منه
مريب وان كلا لما
ليوفينهم ربك
اعمالهم انه بما يعملون
خبير فاستقم كما امرت ومن تاب معك ولا
تطغوا
انه بما تعملون
بصير ولا تركنوا
الى الذين ظلموا فتمسكم
النار وما لكم من دون الله من
اولياء ثم لا
تنصرون واقم الصلاه طرفي النهار وزلفا من
الليل ان الحسنات يذهبن
السيئات ذلك ذكرى للذاكرين
واصبر فان الله لا يضيع اجر
المحسنين فلولا كان من القرون من قبلكم
اولو
بقيه ينهون عن الفساد في الارض الا
قليلا الا قليلا ممن
انجينا منهم واتبع الذين ظلموا ما اترفوا
وكانوا
مجرمين اترفوا فيه وكانوا
مجرمين وما كان ربك ليهلك القرى بظلم
واهلها
مصلحون ولو شاء ربك لجعل الناس
امه
واحده ولا يزالون مختلفين الا من رحم ربك
ولذلك
خلقهم ولذلك خلقهم
وتمت كلمه ربك لام لان جهنم من الجنه
والناس
اجمعين وكلا نقص عليك من
انباء الرسل ما نثبت به
فؤادك
وجاءك في هذه الحق وموعظه وذكرى
للمؤمنين وقل للذين لا يؤمنون اعملوا على
مكانتكم انا
عاملون
وانتظروا انا
منتظرون ولله غيب السماوات والارض واليه
يرجع الامر كله فاعبده وتوكل
عليه وما ربك بغافل
وما ربك بغافل
عما
تعملون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم را تلك ايات الكتاب
المبين انا
انزلناه قرانا عربيا لعلكم
تعقلون نحن نقص عليك من احسن القصص بما
اوحينا
اليك بما
اوحينا اليك هذا
القران
وان ونقص
عليك نحن نقص عليك احسن القصص بما
اوحينا
اليك بما
اوحينا اليك هذا القران
وان كنت من قبله لمن
الغافلين اذ قال يوسف لابيه يا ابت اني
رايت احد عشر
كوكبا اني رايت احد عشر كوكبا والشمس
والقمر والشمس والقمر رايتهم لي
ساجدين قال يا بني لا تقصص رؤياك على
اخوتك فيكيدوا لك
كيدا ان الشيطان
للانسان عدو
مبين وكذلك يجتبيك ربك ويعلمك من تاويل
الاحاديث ويتم نعمته عليك وعلى ال يعقوب
كما
اتمها كما اتم امها على ابويك من قبل
ابراهيم
واسحاق ان ربك عليم
حكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين لقد كان في يوسف
واخوته ايات
للسائلين اذ قالوا ليوسف واخوه احب الى
ابينا منا ونحن عصبه ان
لفي ضلال
مبين اقتلوا يوسف او اطرحوه
ارضا يخل لكم وجه ابيكم يخل لكم وجه ابيكم
وتكونوا من بعده قوما
صالحين قال
قائل منهم لا تقتلوا لا تقتلوا يوسف
والقوه في غيابه الجب
يلتقطه بعض السياره ان كنتم
فاعلين قالوا يا ابانا م لك لا تامنا على
يوسف وانا له
لناصحون ارسله معنا غدا يرتع ويلعب وانا
له
لحافظون قال اني
ليحزنني ان تذهبوا به واخاف ان ياكله
الذئب وانتم عنه
غافلون قالوا لئن اكله الذئب ونحن عصبه
انا اذا
لخاسرون فلما ذهبوا به
واجمعوا ان يجعلوه في غيابه الجب واوحينا
اليه لتنبئنهم
بامرهم هذا وهم لا
يشعرون
وجاءوا اباهم
عشاء
يبكون قالوا يا ابانا انا ذهبنا نستبق
وتركنا يوسف وتركنا يوسف عند متاعنا فاكله
الذئب وما انت بمؤمن لنا ولو كن نا
صادقين وجاءوا على قميصه
بدم كذب قال بل سولت لكم انفسكم امرا
فصبر
جميل والله المستعان على ما
تصفون
وجاءت
سياره فارسلوا واردهم فادلى
دلوه قال يا بشرى هذا
غلام واسروه
بضاعه والله عليم بما
يعملون وشروه بثمن بخس دراهم معدوده دراهم
معوده وكانوا فيه من
الزاهدين وقال الذي اشتراه من مصر لامراته
اكرمي
مثواه اكرمي مثواه عسى ان
ينفعنا او نتخذه
ولدا وكذلك مكنا ليوسف في الارض
ولنعلمه ولنعلمه من تاويل
الاحاديث والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر
الناس لا
يعلمون ولما بلغ اشده اتيناه حكما
وعلما وكذلك نجزي المحسنين وراودته التي
هو في بيتها عن نفسه وغلقت الابواب وقالت
هيت لك قال معاذا
الله انه ربي احسن
مثواي انه لا يفلح
الظالمون ولقد همت به وهم بها لولا ان راى
برهان ربه كذلك لنصرف عنه السوء والفحشاء
انه من عبادنا
المخلصين واستبق الباب وقدت
قميصه واستبق الباب وقدت قميصه من دبر قال
انه واستبق الباب وقتت قميصه من دبر وال
فيا سيدها لدى الباب قالت ما جزاء من اراد
باهلك سوءا الا الا ان يسجن او عذاب اليم
قال هي راودتني عن نفسي وشهد شاهد من
اهلها ان كان قميصه قد من قبل فصدقت وهو
من
الكاذبين وان كان قميصه وان كان قميصه قد
من دبر فكذبت وهو من
الصادقين فلما راى قميصه قد من دبر قال
قال انه من
كيدكن ان
كيدكن عظيم يوسف اعرض عن هذا واستغفري
لذنبك انك كنت من
الخاطئين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
بسم الله الرحمن ال وقال نسوه في المدينه
امراه العزيز الان حص وقال نسوه في
المدينه امراه
العزيز وقال نسوه في المدينه امراه العزيز
ترابد فتاها عن
نفسه وقال
نسوه في المدينه امراه العزيز تراود ف ها
عن نفسه قد شغفها حبا انا لنراها في ضلال
مبين فلما سمعت بمكرهن ارسلت اليهن واعتدت
لهن متكا واتت واتت كل واحده منهن سكينا
وقالت اخرج
عليهن فلما
راينه كبرنه وقطعن ايديهن وقلن حاش
لله وقلن حاش لله ما هذا بشرا ان هذا الا
ملك
كريم قالت
فذلكن الذي لمتنني فيه ولقد راودته عن
نفسه
فاستعصم ولئن لم يفعل ما امره ليسجنن
وليكون من
الصاغرين قال ربي السجن احب الي مما
يدعونني
اليه والا تصرف عني كيدهن اصب اليهن واكن
من
الجاهلين فاستجاب له ربه فصرف عنه
كيدهن انه هو السميع
العليم ثم بدا لهم من من بعد ما راوا
الايات
ليسجننه حتى
حين ودخل معه السجن فتيان قال
احدهما
اني اراني اعصر
خمرا وقال الاخر اني اراني احمل فوق راسي
خبزا تاكل الطير منه نبئنا
بتاويله انا نراك من
المحسنين قال لا ياتيكما طعام ترزقانه
الا نباتك بتاويله قبل ان
ياتيكما ذلكما مما علمني
ربي اني تركت مله قوم لا يؤمنون
بالله لا يؤمنون بالله وهم بالاخره هم
كافرون واتبعت مله
اباء ابراهيم واسحاق
ويعقوب ما كان
لنا ان نشرك بالله من
شيء ذلك من فضل الله علينا وعلى الناس
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يشكرون يا صاحبي السجن اارباب
متفرقون خير ام الله الواحد
القهار ما تعبدون من
دونه الا
الا
اسماء
سميتموها
انتم
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما انزل
الله ما انزل الله بها من
سلطان ان الحكم الا
لله امر الا تعبدوا الا
اياه ذلك الدين القيم ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون يا صاحبي السجن
اما احدكما فيسقي ربه
خمرا واما الاخر فيصلب فتاكل الطير من
راسه قضي الامر الذي فيه
تستفتيان وقال للذي ظن انه ناج منهم
اذكرني عند ربك
فانساه الشيطان ذكر ربه فلبث في السجن بضع
سنين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين وقال الملك
اني ارى سبع بقرات سمان ياكلهن سبع عجاف
ياكلهن سبع عجاف
وسبع سنبلات خضر واخرى
يابسات يا ايها الملا افتوني في رؤياي ان
كنتم للرؤيا
تعبرون قالوا اضغاث
احلام وما نحن بتاويل الاحلام
بعالمين وقال الذي نجى منهما وادكر بعد
امه انا ينبئكم بتاويله
فارسون يوسف ايها الصديق افتنا افتنا في
سبع بقرات سمان ياكلهن سبع عجاف وسبع
سنبلات وسبع سنبلات خضر واخرى يابسات لعلي
لعلي ارجع الى الناس لعلهم يعلمون
قال تزرعون سبع سنين دابا فما حصدتم فذروه
في
سنبله الا قليلا مما
تاكلون ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك سبع شداد ياكلن
ما قدمتم لهن الا
قليلا الا قليلا مما
تحصنون ثم ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك عام فيه
يغاث
الناس فيه يغاث الناس وفيه
يعصرون وقال الملك ائتوني به فلما
جاءه الرسول قال ارجع الى ربك فاساله ما
بال النسوه ما بال النسوه اللاتي قطعن
ايديهن ان ربي
بكيدهن
عليم قال ما خطبكن اذ
راوت يوسف عن نفسه قلنا حاش لله ما علمنا
عليه من
سو قالت امراه العزيز الان حصحص الحق انا
راودته عن نفسه
وانه لمن
الصادقين
ذلك ليعلم اني لم اخنه
بالغيب
وان الله لا يهدي كيد
الخائنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حم
نا الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر التحيه
[Silence]
لله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
س
استقيم صلاه الوتر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
الع
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان ما لها
يومئذ تحدث اخبارها بان ربك اوحى
لها يومئذ يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن
يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا يره الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده رب
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين والعاديات ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به
جمعا ان الانسان لربه
لكنود
وانه على ذلك
لشهيد
وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في
القبور وحصل ما في
الصدور ان ربهم بهم يومئذ
لخبير الله اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر الله اكبر
يا
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين ربنا اتنا من لدنك رحمه وهيئ لنا
من امرنا رشدا واجعلنا من عبادك السعدا
واغفر لنا في الاخره والاولى اللهم نقنا
من خطايانا كما ينقى الثوب الابيض من
الدنس اللهم اغسلنا من خطايانا
بالماء والثلج
والبرد اللهم احسن خواتيمنا اللهم احسن
خواتيمنا ووفقنا لما تحب وترضى اللهم انا
نسالك من خير ما سالك منه نبيك محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم ونعوذ بك من شر ما استعاذك
منه نبيك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم اللهم
حبب الينا الايمان وزينه في قلوبنا وكره
الينا الكفر والفسوق والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين ربنا اغفر لنا ولاخواننا الذين
سبقونا
بالايمان ولا تجعل في ق قلوبنا غلا للذين
امنوا ربنا انك رؤوف
رحيم ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا انك
على كل شيء قدير اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر
واجعلنا من عتقائك من النار ومن المقبورين
ومن
المقبولين اللهم اغفر لنا ولابائنا
ومهات ولاصحاب الحقوق ق علينا واغفر
للمؤمنين والمؤمنات والمسلمين والمسلمات
احياء
وامواتا اللهم انصر عبادك المستضعفين في
كل مكان اللهم انصرهم في فلسطين والسودان
وفي كل بقاع الارض يا رب
العالمين اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من
خوف اللهم اشف جرحاهم وتقبل شهداءهم
اللهم انا نستودعك اياهم يا رب العالمين
فاحفظهم بحفظك واكفهم برعايتك يا اكرم
الاكرمين ويا ارحم الراحمين وصلى الله
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ه